build it draw it play it Vsauce this is
your home for some of the greatest
creations from everyday people
this is bdp build it
ian heath built this adventure time
diorama out of Legos for BrickCon 2011
while Andrew Ainsworth teaches everyone
how to build the original stormtrooper
helmet from Star Wars he was the
original maker of stormtrooper armor in
1976 and you can find the link below to
watch the full video mario has been
making some appearances at various
grocery stores thanks to some creative
soft drinks stalkers and it's not a warp
pipe but these drain pipe hotels in
Austria were built to be open to the
public and a pay what you want place to
stay for the night drawn bill Waterson
son now has his bedroom wall painted
with a scene from Calvin and Hobbes old
floppy disks are given new life by Nick
Gentry in this floppy disk art
collection and Jared Gibson creates
typographic movie posters with an iconic
image from the film filled with its most
famous quotes gulp set a world record as
the largest stop-motion animation set
with the biggest scene stretching over
11,000 feet
play it the speaking piano is a
mechanically controlled piano created by
an Austrian composer that plays MIDI
events that talk like this eric
calderone has a ton of incredible heavy
metal metal EES here's a new one for
Harry Potter
if six strings aren't enough Keith
medley has a 27 string guitar
finally this Croatian do all plays
Nirvana's smells like teen spirit on
cello
we're not done yet submit your own Biddy
Peas at facebook.com slash vsauce gaming
and as always thanks for watching